Good afternoon, everybody.
This is Peter Cooper from the NCBI.
Today's webinar shows you some teaching examples
using our BLAST service.
This is the second in the series of teaching
example handouts that we distribute at conferences
and on our FTP site.
This was presented in part at a cell biology
conference a few years ago.
My name is Peter Cooper, if you need to get
in touch with me that's my email address.
Peter.Cooper@NIH.gov.
As I mentioned we have these case study teaching
examples.
There are three of them on the FTP site.
We talked about the one using EntrezDirect
the last time that I gave webinar.
This time we are using BLAST.
The idea is you can use them to teach undergraduate
courses that involve bioinformatics and BLAST
as a starting point for making your own examples.
Here's what we will do today.
We will talk a little bit about BLAST.
A few tips about BLAST that everybody should
know.
A little evangelism about things that we in
blast-help think people should know.
Talk about some related alignment services.
Then we will go through the examples.
Five different ones.
One of them is two parts.
One will be identifying bacteria using the
16S rRNA.
Designing primers for a gene product.
We will make some trees using some of the
add-ons to BLAST.
We will do one that shows the phylogeny of
the apes using mitchondrialgenomes.
One that shows the protein evolution where
there are a number of paralogs of creatine
kinases.
Annotate an unannotated bacterial contig.
And then map a protein.
In fact the same one we got from the bacteria
contig, onto a conserved domain, and a 3D
structure.
So a couple of things.
What is BLAST?
This is the most widely used sequence similarity
tool in the world.
It finds high-scoring local alignments between
two sequence.
It includes a model of score distributions
for random local alignments, which means it
can provide statistical significance for alignments.
The main statistic is the Expect value, the
number of hits with the same or better score
than expected by chance.
In practice, it doesn't come up that much
in people's everyday searches.
We will talk about that in a moment.
A reminder of what BLAST tells you about.
It tells you about non-chance similarities
between biological sequences.
If they're not due to chance, then they are
due to something else.
Homology, is the classic thing that BLAST
is about.
These are related because they evolved from
the common ancestors.
But in practice, a lot of times BLAST is used
simply to identify something.
We'll talk more about that in a moment.
In order to use BLAST you have to have a nucleotide
or protein sequence.
These are the three related things blast does.
You can answer the following questions.
What is my sequence related to and what does
it do?
This is about homology or conserved domains.
Is it already in the database?
Identification.
Find the matching sequence or you could find
the organism that sequence probably belong
to.
And the last thing is about assembly or annotation
issues.
Where is it located?
How is it organized?
What kind of things are on my sequence?
The evangelism part I wanted to mention.
This has to do with the size of the BLAST
databases.
They are quite large.
The default ones are enormous.
In general the bigger the search space the
longer the search takes.
I will add the more likely it is to fail.
And the expect value for a particular hit
increases linearly with the size of the database.
That is kind of a cryptic statement.
It means this, you're much more likely to
be able to get and interpret your results
if you search the smallest database that is
likely to contain the target of interest.
That is one of the things I want to make clear.
Most searches are against the default databases.
We will look at some of these.
Refseq protein, the model organisms database.
The 16S rRNA database.
Always, I can't think of an example when he
wouldn't want to do this, use an organism
or an Entrez query to limit to reduce the
database size.
You can adjust the expect value cutoff to
limit to significant matches.
Here a couple more words about the program.
The nucleotide search programs by default
use megablast.
There will be times when you may need to make
the more that search more sensitive.
You can change the nucleotide search program.
For protein searches you can do a straight
BLASTP.
You can also translate and we will do a blastx
search to look at an unannotated nucleotide
sequence.
We will do a conserved domains search.
Which tells us about functional elements or
similar kinds of structures.
This has a greater look back time.
It tells you more about the structure function
of a protein than ordinary BLAST.
That runs every time you run a BLASTP search.
We will use some other alignment services.
They are not BLAST they are related.
Primer blast.
Which will help you design primers that are
specific.
MOLE-BLAST is a demonstration program but
we will use it with the 16S as a good thing
for clustering and finding out what the sources
are, and COBALT our protein multiple alignment
tool.
How do you get to BLAST?
Go to the BLAST homepage.
Access to all programs.
Any of the main programs you can change what
kind of search are doing right on the page.
The other tools listed at the bottom are the
ones we will use today.
MOLE-BLAST, primer blast, and multiple alignment.
Here the things will do.
Identify uncultured bacterial 16S sequences.
Design primers to amplify the coding region
of a gene the human myeloperoxidase, MPO,
transcript and exon 10 of the gene.
Make phylogenetic trees based on the ape mitochondrial
genome sequences, including human.
Also tetrapod vertebrate creatine kinase genes.
Tetrapods are creatures with 4 legs like us,
we call two of them arms.
Annotate coding regions on a prokaryotic genomic
sequence metagenome.
Find conserved domains in that uncharaterized
protein.
What I will do for each search is set it up
and go ahead and show you what happens when
we do it.
The first one will be identifying these 20
uncultured 16S rRNA's in the database.
We can use our 16S rRNA type strains database
on the BLAST page, get a distant tree of the
results.
Manipulate those things.
And we can look at MOLE-BLAST.
Let's set that up.
I will go to the website.
What I have up here is a cheat sheet for me.
And this is one of the documents that is in
there.
We can use these 20 uncultured bacterial sequences
listed here.
I made myself a link, a URL to retrieve these.
There they are.
You don't actually need to visit the BLAST
homepage to run BLAST from the nucleotide
pages.
You can click this run BLAST link here.
My 20 are in there.
This is where we will do some things to help
us, we're going to change the database.
The sequences I'm talking that are in the
default database.
The one we want is the 16S rRNA sequence database.
That contains type strains sequences that
NCBI has curated and identified.
Not everything is in there but a lot of things
are in there.
We can set this up and run the search and
to save time I won't run the searches.
I have the RIDs.
We can retrieve that.
These should last for several months.
There is also a link that will help you set
up the page the way I have it set up.
You can use this compressed URL link and that
will set it up.
I will go ahead and retrieve the results.
So we can take a look at them.
This is the 20 sequences and we have 20 different
results pages here.
You will not get them all on one page.
You can do that by downloading them.
You can see if we managed to identify them.
What we can do to do that is see we have the
coverage of 99% where we have the type strain
name.
We can be confident this is probably a good
species or genus level identification of the
sequence.
You can run through them one at a time to
see if they have been identified fairly closely.
For any one of these, you could take a look
at a distance tree of results here.
I will do it for this one.
We will come back to this in a little bit.
You can see where it fits in here.
You can expand this.
You can see what organisms are in there.
I can zoom in to find that query sequence
if you want to.
It is clustered right there with Shigella.
We can be confident that is probably Shigella
sequence.
A lot of these will clustered together.
As an extension of this we can use MOLE-BLAST
to show a way of clustering these things together.
I will show you that quickly . I will go back
over here to my link, MOLE-BLAST is linked
on the BLAST homepage.
I think I need moleblast.cgi in the link.
I can take those sequences we had a moment
ago and put them all in there.
Now I'll change my database.
Here is the 16S rRNA and I will run that.
This does a blast search but is also does
a full multiple sequence alignment.
Then it will give me a tree.
What's good about this it clusters them not
only with the 16S sequences but also with
each other.
So I selected several from the same species
and we will see that result show up here.
While it is cooking, I will go back to my
slides and I will come back to that in a moment.
The next thing I want to show you is how to
use primer blast.
We will design primers for a myeloperoxidase.
We will use the features table to get a subregion.
We will design primers.
Will check primers.
We will use some of the special databases,
refseq databases, that are on the primer blast
page to make your results more specific.
Let's let MOLE-BLAST continue to run, I will
go back over here and start on this particular
one.
What I will do is retrieve the sequence.
This is a myeloperoxidase sequence.
This is a human mRNA.
What we might want to do is amplify a particular
portion of this from some kind of cDNA experiment
or library.
We can go down to the features table and select
the CDS the coding region.
If I click on that it highlights it for me.
There is the atg start.
I can display this it doesn't matter what
format.
Then what I can do is go over here and Pick
Primer.
That will give me the sequence as a template
in primer blast.
There are all kinds of settings.
I will leave those alone.
The main thing primer blast does that is blast
is it checks the primers at the end to see
if they will amplify additional things in
the database.
You have to set a database.
This is the organism limit.
That is the tax ID for humans.
Exactly the same as doing this.
We can run that.
Primer blast takes a moment to run.
I will go ahead and cut to the chase and show
you my results.
One of the things I had to do that is pointed
out instructions, the size of the amplified
sequences large.
Over 2400.
That is a bit large for PCR.
People usually want shorter than that.
I had to adjust that parameter on primer blast
to get this result.
Then I have a set primers here.
There are 10 primer pairs by default, they
should be equally good.
They would amplify this entire coding region
here that is highlighted here in the viewer
of the mRNA sequence.
So we are back to looking at MOLE-BLAST . This
shows you that we have the results.
I want to point out that we can see those
now.
One of the things about the treeviewer is
if you have a big screen, it works better
than it does on a laptop which is where we
are now.
You can see our bacterial clones and how they
cluster within the different groups of bacteria
here.
And they cluster with each other.
These are probably from very closely related
organisms.
We probably don't have this organism represented
in our database.
These that have longer branches.
Going back to what we were doing before.
Which is working on primer blast.
I will close MOLE-BLAST.
One of the things you might want to do is
to see if our primers that we designed would
amplify these particular sequences from other
organisms.
So I can basically take these primers and
put them back in primer blast and use primer
blast in a different way.
I will show you that set up.
I will take the two primers we just designed.
What I have done is changed the organism restriction
so we are now looking at primates.
We can see if we can amplify this transcript
from other primates transcriptomes that we
have in the database.
That result is over here.
Here is one of the Gibbons.
We would amplify that.
The human one we know about that.
Here's a gorilla.
Chimpanzee.
Bonobo.
One of the orangutans.
I'm not sure with SEVIS is, an old world monkey.
You can see that some of these have mismatches.
And if you adjust your stringency properly
you might not amplify them.
but for the higher primates you only have
one mismatch.
Chances are they would probably work.
You can do exactly the same thing on the RefSeq
gene record for this.
I won't do that now.
You you could easily get exon 10 from the
feature table and analyze that to find primers
that would amplify that.
Let's do one of the phylogenetic trees and
I think the ape mitochondrial genome is a
good one to do.
We will restrict the particular database,
refseq_genomic contains all of our RefSeq
genomic sequences.
We are going to limit it to apes.
We will use an organism and an entrez filter
to limit it to just the sequences of interest.
Then we can manipulate the treeviewer display
to get a particular kind of tree out of this.
Let's go to website again.
what I want to do is to get a particular sequence
as a query.
What I have done is chosen what a lot of taxonomists
call and an outgroup sequence.
This is from a primate that is more distanly
related to apes.
Like humans.
This is a ring tailed lemur.
To set this up I would choose run BLAST here.
Change my database.
To RefSEq Genomic . Enter my organism name
here.
Which is hominoidea, which is a super family
that contains humans and other apes.
I will also put an Entrez query limit in here,
mitochondrion[filter], that would limit to
mitochondrial sequences.
Sometimes there are mitochondrial sequences
within the nuclear genome.
This is the mitochondrial genome of the lemur
up here, the query NC_004025.1
I will pick one of the more sensitive algorithm.
Discontiguous mega blast.
You can adjust the algorithm parameters down
here such as the E value.
I want to make it so things are stringent.
I can put in 1e-64.
Then there would be no chance that these are
random alignments.
These will be things that are distinctly significant.
I will retrieve that result for you.
Now I have hits to several of the great apes
here.
You might recognize the names, chimpanzees,
gorillas, siamang and the gibbons.
I can use the Distance tree of results link
to get the tree.
This is an interesting display.
Something more useful may be to change the
way this is laid out.
Make it a circular tree.
Here are the humans you will notice there
are extinct humans.
Hominims.
The closest relatives to us are the chimpanzee
and bonobo.
Here are the other great apes in the same
family.
The family hominidae is here.
These are the gibbons here.
Here is our outgroup, the lemur.
This is an example that you can run yourself.
This is homology search using the creatine
kinases.
It is the same principle as the one we just
did, except that this time we'll be making
a protein tree.
Because there are numerous paralogs in here
you will have multiple homologues in the same
species (paralogs).
The extension of this is you can run COBALT
directly from the BLAST result to generate
your tree.
It is exactly the same procedure.
You can use the links in the handout to get
there if you want to.
We will go ahead and do this one and we will
need to wrap up.
This is identifying a coding region on a genomic
sequence.
We're going to use a sequence from a marine
metagenome, it is unannotated.
Search against a small database called Landmark.
It will give us some good matches.
It contains representatives from all groups
of organisms, bacteria, archaea, plants, animals.
Let's go to the website.
Start with a contig from this prokaryotic,
marine metagenome.
This
has no annotation associated with.
You can run BLAST with it.
And what we will do is change this up.
We will go to a translating BLAST search.
This is blastx.
Use the bacteria and Archaea genetic code.
And we will use the Landmark Model Organisms
database.
You can leave it like this with bacteria and
archea.
Or I can do the whole thing and leave it wide
open.
I think the one I showed you was leaving the
whole thing wide open.
I did change a couple of parameters here.
The E value threshold was set to a more significant
value.
1e-6, which I suggest you always do.
I set the word size from the default of 6
to 3 to make it a more sensitive search.
Let's take a quick look at those results.
Here is our query sequence.
Each one of these matches is to a protein
from one of the organism's proteomes in the
database.
For example here is a hef nuclease.
ANother helicase.
These are all related proteins.
Here is a DNA topoisomerase I.
The other titles in this position are all
DNA topoisomerase I. Here is a tRNA ligase
for alanine.
Annotated that way from various organisms.
The homology extends across into the plants.
You see evidence for six protein coding genes.
The best hit is to this Archaeal sequences.
Down here in the Alignments you have the coding
region.
We've matched a certain part of the query
sequence, which is nucleotide sequence coordinates.
The query ends here and notice it is on the
opposite strand, frame minus 3.
Notice what we don't have are the coordinates
of the actual open reading frame.
An extension of this example is to use that
with our ORFfinder tool, which is in the document,
to get the complete open reading frame.
In fact if you do that, you will find that
you get a complete open reading that you can
use in the next example, which is a BLAST
search against PDB where you can find a structure
module and a conserved domain.
We've run over time.
I will stop here and point you to the document
itself.
You can take a look at the additional examples
that are in there.
Hopefully you will find them useful in any
teaching that you have to do using BLAST.
There are five or probably six if you count
the two trees is two different examples.
Examples that you can adapt easily to teaching.
I think they would be useful for developing
teaching exercises for undergraduate courses.
The last slide has links to some URLs that
are relevant to the material we talked about
today.
And material in the handout.
The Teaching by Example, the five different
ones, are available in our Factsheets directory.
ftp.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov/pub/factsheets/
Let's take a few minutes for questions.
Do we have any?
[Wayne Matten speaking] So one question was,
for the ape mitochondria search, why did not
lemur show up in the results?
[Peter Cooper speaking] The reason lemurs
did not show up because I limited the database
by using an organism query.
And I limited it to the superfamily Hominoidia,
which in our taxonomy database maps to the
commone word ape.
That contains the great apes which are the
humans, chimps, and gorillas.
And orangutans and gibbons.
The lemur is a primate but it is not part
of that superfamily.
The query sequence does not show up in our
results.
Had we used primates, we would have gotten
the lemur sequence in our results.
[Wayne] One more, a general question, What
is that difference between COBALT and other
multiple sequence aligners like ClustaW?
]Peter] Okay so what's the difference between
COBALT and multiple sequence alignment tools
like ClustalW.
The difference is largely what sort of, a
trick that a lot of multiple alignment tools
use is an initial guide tree to cluster the
sequences before they proceed with the multiple
alignment.
It reduces amount of computation time required.
COBALT uses a constraint.
The constraint is matches to the conserved
domains in the protein.
The constraint we use is the conserved domains
in the proteins themselves to begin to make
a guide tree to generate that alignment.
There is probably a more technical explanation
in the COBALT paper.
They all have their merits and drawbacks.
Multiple alignment tools.
If there are no other questions, Wayne says
no.
This concludes today's webinar.
We did not get to all five examples.
They are all spelled out for you in there.
If you have any questions about this, you
can write to me about those examples.
Peter.Cooper@NIH.gov.
If you have questions about webinars in general
write to our webinars address.
Webinars at NCBI.NLM.NIH.GOV.
Thanks everyone for coming.